[Musique]
à l'occasion de la Semaine européenne de
la mobilité le PA Paris Saclay a
organisé deux tables rondes réunissant
des experts de la mobilité durable des
acteurs de la R&D ainsi que des
opérateurs de mobilité pour débattre des
usages de la mobilité d'aujourd'hui et
des innovations de demain
tous les acteurs présents à ces tables
rondes on convergé pour expliquer que la
ville durable doit absolument limiter
l'usage du véhicule individuel au profit
des nouvelles mobilités que sont le
covoiturage l'autopartage ou les modes
actifs
tant que toutes ces nouvelles mobilités
souhaitent être actives et permettent
demain à tout à chacun de les utiliser
il faut que elle s'insère correctement
dans les espaces urbains pour faciliter
les correspondances avec les transports
en commun et que des aménagements soient
suffisamment sécurisés pour justement
encourager le changement de comportement
et donc pour maîtriser la place de la
voiture ça veut dire que derrière il
faut arriver à coordonner les politiques
de stationnement d'aménagement et de
mobilité pour tendre vers un partage de
l'espace public c'est dans cette
perspective de quartier apaisé et des
carbonés que le PA Paris Saclay a
impulsé aux côtés des acteurs publics et
privés un certain nombre de solutions
innovantes pour accompagner le
changement de comportement on peut citer
le stationnement intelligent qui permet
de reporter le véhicule vers des places
en ouvrage
mutualisés ainsi qu'une solution la
mobilité électrique partagée qui permet
de rendre accessible à la fois au
salarié et au grand public
un service de recharge accéléré ainsi
que à des offres d'autopartage que ça
pour la mobilité professionnelle ou des
déplacements du grand public
la semaine européenne de la mobilité et
l'occasion pour nous aménageurs et
collectivités de faire découvrir ces
nouvelles solutions de mobilité aux
usagers du campus et c'est l'objet des
animations qui ont été présentées
aujourd'hui
[Musique]